You're so fast
Shit
Get Niko!
Nighty-night
So Andy Ryland was a writer he wrote the rush series battlefield rush, and he plays a game
A game that's introduced of to us by Jan actually but andrew
embraced it wholeheartedly and the game is that when you arrive at somebody's house or really when you change location
There's a nerf fight that occurs. Anytime Andrew comes over. He's packing so we need to be ready
to answer the call
unless he killed all of us. well nerf killed all of us
We had this nerf mine that we built it string it up at the front door
Leave the front door open and as long as some other person doesn't walk into the building
Probably get him
Yeah...that'd be great huh like
Actually use a nerf mine like functionally
Especially when he put it on the Internet ( camera blurs ) and ever gets to see him get hit by a nerf mine. How embarrassing?
Oh, man, he's gonna. He's gonna have egg on his face
How's this energy level like this post nap energy level for a vlog I pride myself my nerve tactics over on the stream
We'll do a clear fishing line across the doorway or just leave it open or the hide, it's good
You'll record it without getting seen we all you mean just out of view
Oh, I know we can do trade on just keep telling me doing this for the next hour
This 360 camera is the insta 360 one not 361 degrees but 360 one
plugs into your iPhone, I don't know if they have an Android version you do all the processing and stuff on your phone
I'll hold your phone upside down and boom it works
We've seen this before from the first instant camera just hooks up directly to your phone
You can see a live preview right from your phone, so you look at that
It's a little Nick 3:16 it notice that there is a cool feature on this that I haven't seen ever in any
360 camera, but it's a feature that I've thought about for a very long time and that's to be able to basically
recapture the image after the fact in video mode in video mode
It's kind of hard to describe when I'm talking my so imagine like so a 360 camera right it captures
Everything around you and that's certainly meant to be viewed in like a VR headset or with your phone looking around
but you're only really looking at a small portion at a time now what if instead you wanted to just export out a
16 by 9 image for like your computer screen
But this way you can actually be really fine and where you're looking so it's like being able to reframe an image after the fact
But with your field of view I'm gonna just do a quick test here
I'm just gonna record a quick video. I can go all the way over here to hang out with cool
So here's the video, I literally just recorded pull it up right here 360 image
I can scroll through it like I want now standard 360 video sort of stuff you can like move the screen, but here's something
That's really cool that I've never seen in a 360 camera before I have the ability to
Do what's called free capture and that's where I am literally just using my phone
Frame up new shots and zoom in and out as I want even like zoom out to make a really crazy wide field-of-view image
This is that yeah, this is a second video file that he can make looks like you're holding a DSLR
So what you're saying is, In the future don't have to choose their angles
Can you imagine that yeah like so imagine?
360 cameras get so good that even really zoomed in it still looks as good as well say this camera right here zoom
Then eventually the cameras will become higher resolution which will mean that the crops
Themselves will be much higher quality and eventually might even be able to get bokeh that you get from a nice quality lens I mean
Just look at the pixel 2 or the iPhone. They have portrait mode, which that basically adds fake
Depth of field using fancy sensors and algorithms
They're able to actually fake really good looking depth of field and imagine one day with a 360 camera
That's a 16 K video portrait mode enabled. You won't ever need a regular camera anymore
You'll just walk around with one of these 360 cameras be able to pull snippets from that 360 image
That looks just as good as a regular DSLR in a nice lens today
And you never miss a moment no longer problems where you're looking at the wrong thing at the wrong time wait
I mean, that's the problem for us cuz there's a group of people and you can only look one direction
But if you could look at all the directions at the same time you'll never miss another moment
There will always be a time and a place for regular cameras with specific needs
But a 360 camera that can capture everything and deliver the same quality as a regular DSLR with depth of field and good audio
It's like that is not too far-fetched, and it's coming soon start saving your money because it's coming next fall
Let me not really it's really cool that insta 360 is experimenting with this obviously there's a lot of improvement
But it's pretty good as it is right now. Hey you made a movie?
The movie is done!
Are you ready? Which movie?
Which movie? Tells of the American, Oh the one that we shot the drones for. You bet it's done
It comes in the director's cut comes in at 2 hours and 40 minutes
So here's what you're gonna see when you go to the movie theater, on November 30th
It's a downtown independence you guys I'm gonna sit you get you guys seats
Here's what you're gonna. See you're gonna watch one hour and 20 minutes worth of movie and
and then...
the words
Intermission you're gonna. Have a 20-minute intermission. It will be four songs
From the musicians that have done the soundtrack for the movie the each one of them's got a song okay
so it's just the Easter Jake, robots, lightning Woodcock and
There's a devil dog so you can get up take Pee, buy another beer
Then the house lights will dim like three minutes before I get your a** back into the seats
then watch another hour and 20 minutes of movie it moves like a
Some weird sound made by him
It moves like a freight train it moves. It moves it moves
We just we kept those cuts going there's nobody's ever on the whole thing longer than maybe mmm
12 seconds started shooting Oh God November 30th of
God it's been a project. I will
Already got more ideas and more for more projects and stuff we're doing the posters
And I'm also starting to make phone calls and get people lined up, so I hope you guys are in town on November 30th
Yeah, I'm Congrats
I know what we're doing right now Pam's in the editing room putting on the title credits already
Screened it at the Downtown independent just for us
We need a technical screening wanted to watch the whole thing would it look like on the big screen. I'm telling you right now GoPro
7d, 5d looks great it looks great. This guy you know he's got state of the art
This guy at the dominant event a state of the art
Sound is he the music is incredible? I was shocked
I was shocked at how many different kind of movie cameras we shot with and how good it looks yes, and that adds
So much production value to anything you do drone shots. I don't know how you can do a movie nowadays without one
Hey napoleon, give me one of your totes.
No man
Go outside and tell me if you can you see this yeah
Like right here
Give it up higher. Oh, yeah
Yeah, I don't have a lot experience setting up traps in life some of the things you always think about it's a kid like yeah
Making traps. I really enjoyed home alone. It's a great movie and watch it with like cousins
Back when it came out back when I was really young and you remember there's a scene where he puts nails in the stairwell
they put some nails in the stairwell right step on it, and my cousins and I
Put nails in this sidewalk so something good step on one and get trapped
Hah dude it such a good prank!
It's such a good prank
Get really on you didn't know that much better
Found a bunch of nails...
And we counted them into the cracks in the sidewalk, sticking upside-down sticking up
Then we hid in the bushes and watches people would walk down the sidewalk
Oblivious the fact is pricking metal spikes sticking up not noticing. I'm like
I never they're just one to use like this big guy the big beard a big beard guy like walking on this Howard guy
Like steps on a nail bigger, it's kicked and like maybe like hit, but he did step on a nail somewhere
That's one pushing a stroller. She's pushing a stroller and the stroller she runs over one of the nails and bends it
She doesn't know and then she actually steps on the nail and she stops it doesn't go through Shoe
Thankfully like you have all the things they got at least we didn't actually hurt her she steps on the nail
Stop she looks down
She picks her shoe up and shows the nail stuck in it, and then she looks down the sidewalk his nails all over
Sticking up us being kids something like I realize that that was really hurt and that we could really hurt somebody
And so I kind of like step out and like look at her
She's like did you guys do this and like yeah, we did that?
You're coming with me right now
Where's your public?
Which house are you from where's your brother like this one like I just turned ourselves in and we walked in Wren Get out of here
I'm tell the story
Get out of here get on that onewheel and fly away
Weeee
She knocks on the door in my aunt opens it and she's like what's going on like they put nails my sidewalk
And she's my aunt was so stop at us
So she immediately like you guys a dumb playing niko
You're out you guys. You're grounded, and I had to go back to my grandmother's house. She was understanding
She's like you're just a kid you didn't know any better Home Alone is a good movie. Yeah
Needless to say I now think about the consequences of my actions more
Its pretty good, I can't really see it
Okay, so they say okay, I activated triple switch and in principle
What what happens is that it takes a really really high speed?
It takes a high-speed video as I'm swinging it about myself, and then it plays it back in slow motion
so you swing this around yeah, let's
Let's go over here. This is like literally the jankiest
Manual that came with the camera saying swing the camera around on a string careful not to hit anything
So...
Try it!
Brother for rappers
Baptism it might save souls advances hands listen phonics will attract the brasses in the pockets of the jazz hip-hop magic in
Akeno can't stop, but if you try to
Dance, we provide this so it drives through and as long as we alive - this is mission a star from the kitchen no drive
Through that flow chef in it ain't one prepping
It just got a bottle or tank most definiteness can't question it it's always roll like this. Let go shall
We just always off like y'all. Can't see what we always saw
Those sweepers always flop now we all know
No fear no fear. I got no f**** left again one dream. Good - they can't suck in my cheese
Everyday hustle never touching the dings and you wanna have balancing weight with one bean
Mouse click
All right
We'll see yeah. I mean I it didn't work inside cuz it wasn't enough light
But it's it spins like this really really fast, so I might still get motion blur. I don't know yeah, let's find out
That's the point of an experiment, right?
Get through the backroom
Did you not get by the trap no
Did you happening to get hit by a trap? No
Did it work though?
I don't know if you got hit or not
It may like I'm not gonna say it's impossible to hit me, but I didn't feel anything
( It didn't hit :( )
You like that
Cuz I and then I was looking for parking and I pulled through and I just saw all of you standing here
And I was like oh those tricky Devils
And then Alex told me where you were solid
Man dude just breezes by it
I was like so what's going on in there and all the back from the back there in the room okay?
Good Budapest the speed of the present like the whole tunnel vision thing totally worked, but yeah
You think you did with the real money, it's run faster
I think
That sucks is that I almost had you and I missed you by like ah and then I went in missed you again
And he just got me right in there
Christian was prepared. He was I'm always ready, man